el ejército israelí admitió la alta
probabilidad de que un soldado asesinada
por error irina bucle pero descartó
abrir una causa penal a esa conclusión
no le llegó la investigación de las
fuerzas de defensa de israel sobre el
crimen de la periodista palestino
estadounidense asesinada durante una
redada israelí en jenín el 11 de mayo
pasado el reporte fue presentado en
medio de una creciente presión sobre
todo de eeuu pero se queda corto en
definir responsabilidades porque insiste
en que no es posible determinar
inequívocamente la fuente del disparo un
funcionario militar bajo anonimato
explicó a los medios que los informes de
ese instante coinciden con una
identificación errónea por parte del
soldado pese a que agua cla y su equipo
llevaban chalecos y cascos con la
leyenda de prensa también alegó que el
error podía deberse a que el área era un
campo de batalla y que habían disparos
de todos lados afirmación de la que no
proveyó pruebas y que es discutidas por
testigos e investigaciones periodísticas
independientes que han concluido que no
había combates en ese momento al
considerar que los soldados procedieron
correcta israel no procesará penalmente
a ninguno de ellos algo que rara vez
ocurre de ahí que la familia de agua que
no se sorprendiera ellos señalaron que
como era de esperar israel se ha negado
a asumir la responsabilidad y que es
obvio que los criminales de guerra
israelíes no van a investigar sus
propios crímenes la autoridad palestina
y la cadena al yazira para la que
trabajaba agua que también acusaron a
israel de querer evadir su
responsabilidad mientras que la ong
israelí de derechos humanos b'tselem
dando el informe de débil confesión que
buscar encubrimiento